[Music]
so many great accolades coming up when
did you feel like you've made it they
think that the moment when I was like
was when I when I was in New York with
patty Jenkins and my husband for press
for Wonder Woman and we went to Times
Square when we got there and Times
Square was covered with Wonder Woman
posters so I think that was the moment
when I was like whoa it's like it's
Times Square I've been there so many
times and now I'm you know you want to
know when it does Wonder Woman to start
shooting soon we just spoke with patty
Jenkins she she said it was a foregone
conclusion Brett would not be producing
the movie that whole thing happened
weeks ago so that actually had nothing
to do with I was a conclusion I was
surprised by that story is that
something you supports look there's been
a lot written about how I feel in my
views about this topic and everyone
knows how I feel about it
and the truth is there's so many people
involved in making this movie and they
all you know they all have echoed the
same sentiments
[Music]
you